this is believe it or not
uh well maybe with a bit of a nudge it's
absolutely within the scope
of what you can integrate as an advanced
student not even extension one
watch as i use techniques that are
completely from extension sorry
completely from advanced and not from
extension one just eyes up with me
so you can see this because most of you
have over complicated this quite
dramatically
okay knowing and admittedly i'm giving
you an advantage now you didn't have
before
knowing that you can integrate this as
an advanced student right
this dramatically narrows the number of
things it could possibly be
and therefore the path that you will put
through this right for starters
it's a fraction it's a fraction now if
you hand
an integral to an advanced student and
it has a fraction in it
um it's one of two things either you can
actually simplify out the fraction so
there's never a fraction anymore it's
like oh it's just a simple polynomial
just a simple trig function and off you
go right
or what is that other kind of function
we even talked about it when we're doing
the intro right
that we can deal with and where does it
lead in advance
logarithms right this is a rational
function
literally the only thing you can go to
from an advanced point of view
is a log so i'm looking for some kind of
f dash on f now the last time i checked
1 was not the derivative of x log x i
didn't even know what the derivative of
x log x is off the top of my head
but don't fret i can fairly effortlessly
turn this into
an f dash on f situation
what might be the useful f x to choose
for n one on x i am gonna choose f
uh one on x but i don't think it's
useful f
to choose you're thinking of the yeah
you're doing the next step
so here's my f of x helpful to identify
that first
because f dash is based on this guy
right so i'm going to put that
up the top here do you see how i split
apart this fraction
usually fractions on fractions usually
fractions on fractions are worse
but in this case we know what the
derivative of log x is it's 1 over x
i'm there there's my f dash on f i've
got a definite integral so i'll chuck in
my big square brackets here
when you have f dash on f what does it
integrate into generally speaking
log of whatever that f of x is right
here is my f of x i know it's a bit
weird it's a log itself that's fine
it's log of just to make it really um
how does that black pen red pin guy do
it i don't know how he does it
um that that is the f that i put in
there so it's log of
f of x which in this case is log of log
x you okay with that and from here
i almost feel like i would not like to
do the rest of the question because you
should be able to handle it
what do you think this is these they
usually got that view
you usually got this bit i'll do one
extra line for you and then um
i will trust you to get to a solution um
just when i put this in right
i'm going to get log of log of e squared
there's my upper bound right think about
what's going to happen in here for a
moment
then i'm going to subtract my lower
bound this is log of log
e what's log of e
that's 1 what's log of 1 0. that's 0.
over here a very similar thing happening
except
you're gonna i mean if you wanted to
right just to make it exceptionally lazy
you could just here i really don't know
how it does it um
i can take this power out here make it
the coefficient
so you're gonna get log of 2 times
1 to your logo too you're pretty much
there makes sense
okay that shouldn't have been two ideas
let's have a look at the second one
which i would forgive you for finding a
little bit more troublesome okay
use the derivative of um and i've got
this
inverse trig function nested inside a
product right in order to
work out this other result over here or
prove this other
result all right for starters let's call
this question 2.
who can give me a derivative of x sine
inverse
what do we got sine inverse of x
it's a plus right yep and it's x on
there's our uv dash you happy with that
now um it was
really interesting to me again as an
advanced technique forget about the fact
that this is inverse trig because once
you know that derivative
it just off it goes what you're about to
do now is an advanced
method right when you know a derivative
you can use this as a stepping stone
to an integral what's the thing they
want you to integrate
it's it's sine inverse of x this guy
right here
right so in order to get to the integral
of sine of s of x
what i should do is take this line and
just
integrate everything right um then that
will give me the integral right in the
middle and i've just got to sort out
what's happening on the left and right
hand sides
okay so let's go ahead and give that a
while i'm gonna start in here because
this is the part that i know that i want
one of my boundaries
zero zero and a half right three and a
half so
here comes my definite integral right so
that's the part that i want
and now i've got this other stuff that i
don't want now over here on the right
hand side
i've still got the same kind of whoops
wrong one the same kind of thing
happening over here
it's another definite integral right the
only thing that's different we have to
be careful with is
this over here we're about to integrate
a derivative
integrate a derivative so where's that
going to send us back to
this this original function right except
what we're doing
on the right hand side is is definite it
has boundaries right
so when you go back to integrate this
thing you end up with
well a definite integral just like you
had before
right and this bit's a bit unfamiliar
it's the least familiar part of this
but it's totally doable right we can
manage this right let me give you a bit
of a nudge
upper bounds half times what
sine inverse of a half which is pi on
six
happy times upper bound done lower bound
done
no worries what do i do with this
integral in here
sweet nothing it's exactly what i want
it to be so i'm just going to write it
as
is but this term on the right hand side
this might take a little more massaging
um what am i going to do with this thing
uh i will put in
my zero and my half here i'll leave out
the front for a second
okay how can i write this helpfully what
do you think
think back to your advanced and
extension one toolkit
say it again yeah so
if i put this into an exponential form
get a power in there we're pretty good
at dealing with polynomials like that
right
so i'm going to have an x and a 1 minus
x squared to the power of
a half like so i haven't done any
integration
right all i'm doing here by the way if
you don't if you're not familiar with
this term
you should write it down now because
it's going to be useful all i've done is
i have manipulated the integrand
that's the name of the thing being
integrated right
uh say thank you very much it's on the
denominator
i have manipulated the form of the thing
that's being integrated
to make it more convenient to me okay
now you notice i left off some things
and that's because
whilst i'm doing this i think i can make
this even easier for myself right
this is reverse chain rule or will be in
a second so i want some kind of f
dash f situation yeah i'm almost there
how do i need to change it
yeah that minus 2x will do it which
means that to compensate over here i
should have a
minus a half so that's balanced out is
that okay
and just to be really neat i probably
should put that in brackets okay does
that make sense
now i'm going to pause there because
from here
think about where i need to go right
what's this equal to
pi on 12. is that promising you bet it
is right this is
pretty much what i need right uh this is
the term that i want
and then what i'm going to do next is
i'm going to add this whatever it ends
up being
to both sides it'll end up over here
with the integral that i'm
i'm after okay who's got a finished
result hands up
a few of you about a third okay i'll
give you some time to go on
those of you who have your hands up you
can continue on in 4a these
questions are both from 4a i'll give you
guys a bit of time and then i will show
you what my solution looks like in about
three minutes
okay i only wanted to give you a few
minutes
just because i knew a third of you were
ready to go in 4a but for the two-thirds
of you
who i just gave you your breathing room
to finish this off
i'm not quite there as you can see but
i'm so very close let's make sure we do
it together because
i think there are still quite a few
twists and turns in this
um so let me show you how i've done it
this is the line i left you at so what
have i changed well on the left hand
side with your help i've written this as
pi on 12.
this term remains unchanged because it's
the thing i'm actually after
what's going on here over on the right
hand side
it's negative or minus a half rather
it's out the front that came from me
adjusting the integrand so it would look
really nice in an f dash
and an f to a certain power and then
what have i done
well this is reverse chain rule in here
right i've increased the power by one so
it's gone from just watch out
fractions negatives everything can
possibly go wrong even morgan was the
one who pointed out i forgot to write
the minus sign in the first instance
you add one gives you positive a half
but then after increasing the power
just like within all advanced
integration you divide by that power
that's why i've awkwardly written it as
two over one even though you're like
i do that right to remind you that this
is where that comes from i've divided by
the new power
so that's why it's upside down from here
you can see i thought
well i don't need to keep on writing
this together mixed in with the other
stuff
i want to make this the subject so you
can see it's sort of come
in here on its own it's still on the
right hand side because
i'm doing too many things i just know
what myself is like
i'm going to overload my brain switching
this to one side and also manipulating
this side so that's why i've added this
to both sides but do notice right some
nice cancelling has happened
it's almost like the question was
designed to do this right so
that minus a half which i had at the
front it's gone um why is this a plus
wasn't a minus before
look carefully why is it a plus susie
yeah it was on the right hand side so
really what i've done is i've
added it to both sides hence it being a
plus over here right
we know right this all the hard stuff we
as extension two students we get
and then we get tripped up by a sign
okay i've gone back to
this is 1 minus x squared to the power
of half i've gone back to square root
notation because i only got it into
exponent form as through and suggested
for what purpose
why why did i write it like this so i
could integrate right but i'm done with
that
i'm done this i can now do um in my mind
a lot more easily and now let's
tidy this up and uh get all the loose
ends i'm gonna i'm ready to switch sides
now so i'll pop this zero to a half
here and then on the right hand side i
have the pine 12
that i wanted right i'm now adding okay
just be careful this is a show question
remember so no
skipped steps of logic what's going to
come in here
can you help me do the upper bound
help me out guys sean give me give me a
first step
one minus yeah yep i reckon we can go to
the next one
that's okay all right so there's half
scope um
are you happy with that yeah this is
this is show right i think this
step is an easy one to skip but we're so
close to the variant here
you is worth putting in here right um
you've got your pi on 12.
you've got your square root of three
quarters we're so very close
right and then you've got your minus one
and from here the last line you write
is the line that was the result that was
required of you make sense
what makes this challenging i think is
you have so much extra in your brain
from what you're used to
this is all advanced in extension one
really
so get used to this being um the ground
floor my favorite comparison metaphor
for this is
um mount everest base camp is at 2000
meters
base camp is at 2000 meters does anyone
know how tall kosciuszko is
it's it's it's just under it's just
under 2000 meters right
so where the extension one course ends
that's where we begin in the same way
that where australia ends
everest starts okay we're gonna have fun
in this topic but you have to work hard
and be careful with it